[Music]
hello my name is Brennan Doyle I'm a
solution architect at the Google cloud
it's focusing mostly on media and
entertainment vertical I have with me
here my friend Greg Denton who's a
software engineer our render team we're
going to talk to you a little bit about
open cue and rendering first thing we're
gonna do is we would talk a little bit
about what problem are we trying to
solve and then I'll introduce you to you
two different ways that we can solve it
on GCP and then we'll do an overview of
a new tool that we've open-sourced in
collaboration with Sony Pictures
Imageworks called open cue and then
we'll do a live demo fingers crossed
and then Q&A at the end so what problem
are we trying to solve so basically
there has been growing pressure of new
content being created so with hulu
netflix all these different content
creators there's been an explosion in
unique scripted content so the need for
creating graphics has grown in addition
to that if you look at what we were
doing back in the 1990's Titanic for
instance had 300 shots in it the last
Avengers movie had 3,000 shots in it so
each individual project that comes out
is having like a 10x growth in the
amount of graphics that are needed to
finish that project a somewhat popular
animation studio claims that one of
their more recent film films took them
about 33 hours of frame to render and
when you look at a two hour movie you're
looking at 24 frames a second 60 seconds
a minute 120 minutes is about 170 2,800
frames that's not only math but those
are large numbers when you start to
multiply those by how long it takes per
frame you're looking at five million
seven hundred to four hundred thousand
hours for a single revision of an
animated feature and time equals money
so how do you go about orchestrating
these things in a way that's efficient
and that's what we're here to talk to
you about today so at Google cloud there
are two ways we can help solve the
rendering crisis one of them is using
software as
servus so it's much easier for you to
set up it's generally targeted towards
small and medium-sized business
businesses and the other is building a
custom pipeline using infrastructure as
a service so the two things I'll talk to
you about today are zinc render which is
a turnkey solution for small and medium
business owners to do rendering on the
cloud mostly for burst rendering and
then also open cue which is basically
for larger studios that have custom
pipelines how do we at Google help you
to build something that'll solve
problems for you so a little bit about
zinc zinc is designed by visual effects
artist for visual effects artists it
makes it extremely simple to render
there are several components that that
go into a zinc system basically it
integrates with your existing rendering
software so if you're using any of these
following tools it will work with these
and it's very simple to kick off a job
and render it in the farm basically what
you end up with is a client that manages
all of our transfer to the cloud from
your local workstations to the cloud
copying all the data that is required
for your rendering you install plug-ins
inside of your hosts 3d or 2d
application and then there is a web
console that allows you to manage your
jobs after they've been submitted so you
can move around priorities do
troubleshooting on jobs things of that
nature it's a very simple architecture
zinc would be for yourself a lot of what
we're building out for you is contained
within this compute engine a node right
here which basically everything is a
black box behind the scene happening for
you don't have to worry about that
infrastructure so basically what we're
doing is we're setting up authorization
for your users and then managing all
your transfers and renders so
infrastructure as a service is more what
we're gonna did dig deeply into today
and take a look at open cue but
basically the larger studios that we
work with generally have very unique
pipelines that require them to do very
specific things so they need a tool that
is custom built so in that world
everything is a resource basically each
piece of of the puzzle that is required
to be put together for rendering is a
resource that you need to orchestrate so
you start with your render workers which
are basically your VMs and various sizes
and flavors
and then you can add your persistent
disks for storing data additional discs
that might be needed for holding on to
your pipeline information things that
nature object storage is a backup and
all these need to be orchestrated so
when we stick them together we end up
with something a little bit like this so
rendering VMs are the route of what
we're trying to achieve is being able to
render frames we have some kind of a
storage which is where we are storing
all of our assets they're gonna be
prerequisites for renders we generally
have some kind of NFS file server that
is required to either host your textures
or your pipeline for software and such
there is when we're dealing with a
hybrid connectivity we almost always are
using a read-through cache and then
there's some kind of license server that
needs to be created and some way to
manage your users permissions as well as
something for logging which we use stack
driver for that and your asset
management database and we're here to
talk to you about open queue so for what
we build here today we're using
terraform templates to build out our
infrastructure and to manage
infrastructure is code so it's easy to
spin up modify and move around to
different places if we need it so let's
talk a little bit about what is open Q
open Q is a render orchestration layer
or a queue management system that we've
partnered with Sony Pictures Imageworks
to release to the open source community
so it's available for you now on github
I'll provide some links here in just a
bit it has been used by Sony on hundreds
of films it has been used in various
different deployments as well on pram
hybrid and on the cloud only and has
scaled to many many machines so open Q
can work in a variety of architectures
this is not a tool that we've released
that only works on Google Cloud it was
developed in on an in in and on premise
there we go way of working and you can
see how it would function here it's
basically used to distribute the
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
frames to all of the render hosts that
you are utilizing it's also been used by
them quite consistently for hybrid
deployments here is an example of a
hybrid deployment Sony last year was
discussing they are pretty
at least spitting up like 60,000 CPUs in
the cloud and managing them with open Q
so the deployment we're looking at here
today is basically what we are calling a
virtual studio so at the moment Greg's
gonna do a demo here in just a bit he's
running a virtual workstation out of
Oregon that is connected to his laptop
running a software client from Tara
dieci called and a protocol called PC
over IP so if you were setting up a
studio from scratch it's likely that you
would want to use something like a zero
client which is not a computer but just
a device that allows you connect to that
PC over IP stream and to stream things
back and forth you need some way to
connect to Google Cloud in this instance
we're using the public internet if you
were in production you would be using
either cloud VPN a dedicated
interconnect or you'd work with one of
our partners to share a dedicated
interconnect line so again the the heart
of the matter here is a virtual
workstation running on Google Cloud
which has an Nvidia t4 processor in it
there we go okay and it is how we're
gonna drive our Maya scene file demo and
behind that we're only using a single
machine here so we're not working
through a connection broker but a
connection broker is a layer that allows
your artist if you have hundreds of
artists logging in to a single point it
directs them to their particular
machines and also helps you to manage
their permissions and login data so
today we're running our storage off of
Anna last file scale-out filesystem
which is able to tear to cloud storage
so you have a combination of ability to
customize it for high speed and also use
cloud storage for low cost backup data
we also have a license server running in
the cloud a very small Linux VM which is
serving up our Maya licenses and v-ray
which we'll be doing for rendering today
in addition to that we have our cubot
server so cubot server is a piece of
open queue that I mentioned earlier it
is managing the distribution of the jobs
maintaining the state of our database is
an open queue database running on cloud
sequel which uses a Postgres sequel and
then we've got a group of render workers
in the background so again we've
orchestrated all this using
terraform packer and docker and
currently working on making those
scripts available to everyone through
open source so the types of things that
the cost that you will incur in this
kind of system are all listed out here I
won't go through them I'll let you take
a picture and think about them later if
at the end of this conversation totally
happy to answer any questions that you
have we also have a booth on the far
side over there if you want to come and
have a little deeper chat we're way up
against the back wall there by the
gaming team so let's talk a little bit
about the the architecture of open cue
so open cue has several pieces we have
the see if this works there we go the
cubot server
cubot server is running right now on a
vm in Google cloud platform it is a Java
service that maintains the distribution
of the jobs and also enables you to
login with a GUI and to see the state of
your current queue there is the Postgres
sequel database that's running in the
background
those two are communicating to maintain
a list of what jobs are active and where
all the log files are residing there is
this rqd render host over here these are
our managed instance groups which are
going to be doing the rendering for us
they're running an rqd process and
communicating over these ports back and
forth to the cubot server in addition on
our artist workstation we have a couple
of things a PI Q is a module that
enables us to communicate between Cuba
and the render hosts and the artist
workstation we have a tool called cue
GUI which is the interface for seeing
the list of jobs that are running how we
prioritize those and how we assign jobs
to particular render hosts in addition
to that we have a tool called PI outline
which is assisting us in submitting jobs
open cue ships with a plugin for Maya
and Houdini as new or a nuke Maya and
nuke which enables you just from from
the interface to pull down a menu and
say render to open queue also there are
example scripts on how you could build
them for your own customized pipeline so
since it's open source if you know some
Python you can get in there and script
your own plugins and then there's a
submit application which is running
inside of our
- so just talk a little bit about the
infrastructure that we're seeing and how
we're orchestrating it to configure and
build our render hosts we're using
docker images so basically those docker
images are scripts that allow us to
define all the prerequisites libraries
that need to be installed as well as all
of the third-party software and in some
instances links to where you can check
out licenses those are stored in our
container registry and when we launch a
machine we're launching an instance
template which is reading in that docker
file we also have the Logies went the
wrong way pardon me we also have the
ability to resize our render hosts so at
the moment what we're doing is we're
doing that manually in in this instance
but there the logic is there that if you
wanted to integrate your own instance
our work manager that would look at the
size of your queue and automatically
scale this your manage instance groups
and look for health checks and make sure
that you've got the machines you need
it's quite quite straightforward to put
something together there so I think that
covers just about an overview of open
queue why don't we dive in and take a
look at the tool itself and I'll hand it
over to Greg all right hi everyone
thanks for coming out yeah my name is
Greg Denton I'm a software engineer here
at Google cloud in the media and
entertainment rendering team and so if
we switch over to the demo box I will
jump right in and go ahead and launch
cue GUI so like Brennan was talking
about cue GUI is the primary application
used for monitoring and managing the
render farm it's a PI situ Python
application and it's gonna communicate
back with cubot the central server with
over G RPC and if we look at it right
now there's absolutely nothing to look
at because we have no jobs so we'll jump
over to a shell and go through launching
some jobs so there's two api's there's a
general-purpose Python API that's used
primarily for just any kind of
interaction with with cubot anything you
can do in the UI
you can you through the API and then
there's also the PI outline API PI
outline is going to help build jobs it
gives you a lot of functionality to
orchestrate multiple jobs together and
string them together and submit them so
this is just a simple Python script
that's using those two api's will go
ahead and run it it's kicked off three
jobs to the farm and you can see that
they've shown up over here in Cuba E and
now that we have some jobs let's talk
about what a job actually is as far as
the open queue is concerned so jobs
broken down into three separate levels
you have the job and that's really just
a container for the submission and if we
click on one of them we will see that
it's it hosts information about what
user submitted it what facility it was
submitted from what show it's for what
shot that kind of metadata and then if
you descend down to a separate level the
next one down here is a layer so a layer
is going to be you can think of it as a
command to run with a frame range
associated with it you can have multiple
layers populating a single job and
dependencies set up between those and
then the layer also is going to keep
track of the requirements for that job
so if you want to say that this type of
command is going to use four cores in
this example that's where you're going
to set that same for memory and GPU
requirements the next level down is
going to be the frame and the frames can
be the individual instance of that
command with a single frame or frame
chunk depending on how your submission
set up and it's gonna be the command
that actually gets run on the host
itself so we can see these guys are all
running and kicking away it's gonna keep
track of things like your runtime the
exact amount of resources that are used
and all those stats were then bubbled up
to the higher levels so you get a
summary view
of what is actually been running so cue
GUI is actually built up as two separate
applications you have cue topia what
we're looking at here and cue commander
so cue topia is more made for a single
artist looking at their jobs trying to
see if their submissions are running
when they're when they'll finish are
they finished any errors that kind of
stuff a cue commander is more made for a
admin or render Wrangler to be able to
get a higher level view of the farm be
able to have a lot more controls over
the management of the farm so as we dive
a little deeper we'll jump over to cue
commander and the first thing that we're
gonna take a look at here is the monitor
cue of you so this is just a high-level
view of everything that's currently
active in the farm and you'll be able to
see this across all users and it gives
admins the ability to group jobs that
are similar and control them all
together so for instance if you wanted
to change the priority of multiple jobs
altogether or change the requirements
you could do that from here and so the
next thing that we're gonna go over is
kind of how what's what groups
everything in open cue and so the
highest level object is a show and all
jobs are gonna be submitted to a show
you can see some really simple
information about what kind of cores are
running what what frames were running
for the show we only have a single show
here it's the testing show and we can do
things from here I accept the maximum
number of cores minimum number of cores
for jobs in that show I enable and
disable booking all that kind of stuff
alright so we've gone over jobs a bit
let's talk now about
host so if we open up the monitor host
view and we'll refresh this to populate
it come on this is gonna show us all of
our render workers so the render workers
right now are all configured to be
identified by their IP address and you
can also have them configured to look be
identified by their hostname if that
makes more sense for you it's pretty
customisable from that point of view and
it's we can see that we have like 3000
render hosts all up and running
thanks to Adrienne's demo from before
and they're all still kickin so this
view is gonna give you a lot of
information about what type of host you
have all of our hosts here are running
inside has seen a single managed
instance group and like Brendan was
talking about that's running out of aus
West one and they're reporting that they
have four cores
all of them are idle right now in 30
gigs of ram so this is counting the
physical cores on the box so that
correlates to eight core 30 gig and in
one preemptable eight machine so the
other information that's useful here is
the ping time so it's showing you when
was the last time that machine checked
in and if that goes beyond a certain
threshold cubox gonna consider that
machine down and stop dispatching any
additional work and if there's any work
that was running on that that'll get
moved over to another host this works
well for a preemptable workflow because
our managed instance group is going to
go ahead and replace any instances that
get preempted and then cubot is going to
see that preemption and reschedule to
work for you so works entirely in the
preemptable fashion if you want
and so let's go ahead and go back to
utopia here and we have a bunch of our
jobs have finished but we have a few
that are still running and if we go to a
house and let's sort this by what's idle
so what I'm looking for here is a host
that's actually running something and
one of the cool things about open queue
is it has a way of dynamically
allocating slots for jobs to run so like
I was talking about all of these hosts
are four core hosts and let's say if you
submitted a job that's only we're gonna
require one core open queue is going to
carve out what's called a proc and
that's what we're showing down here and
it's only gonna carve out whatever the
job requires leaving the rest of the
proxy vailable to be used so for
instance you could run for one core
procs on a single host or two two cores
however your job and the dispatcher
decides to do it so we have jobs notes
now covered how do jobs actually get to
house for that we'll start talking about
how do we group hosts so there's a
concept called an allocation and an
allocation is really just a mechanism
for grouping multiple hosts and
controlling them together so we can see
that Oliver our render host right now
are running inside this local general
allocation and that's gonna be
identified by a facility where the the
host is actually running and then a
single tag that we want a patch or pass
through all of the hosts in that
allocation and then we have a
subscription in a subscription
a subscription is gonna be a way of
providing rules to an allocation so if
we select our show we can see that the
testing show has subscribed to the
following allocations and here we can
also specify the amount of resources
from that allocation that we want the
host to have as well as a burst amount
the burst amount is going to allow
multiple shows to share a single
allocation and be able to steal
resources when available there and so
the next thing if that's our way of
grouping and managing hosts services our
mechanism for grouping and managing jobs
so every job can be submitted to a
service in this case we're looking at
the Arnold service and it's gonna
provide some D for default resource
requirements for that job the job can
specify anything else it wants on top of
that but these are going to be the
defaults in this case you're able to
specify that it's going to be a
threadable it's gonna be able to use
however many threads you want and the
minimum number of threads required this
is a percentage amount so saying that it
is 100 here means that it's going to use
1 cor you can obviously go above that
and then the maximum is set at 0 saying
essentially saying that there's no
maximum
we are also specifying min minimum
memory requirements for that proc so
it's only gonna carve out a proc from
the host if that memory is available and
if there's any GPU requirements the last
thing that the service is going to do is
apply these tags to the jobs that are
there so now putting this all together
if we go back to our queue taupey of you
and look at these jobs we can select the
job and look at its attributes and we
can see that it is in fact submitted to
the local facility
and it's using the testing show and then
if we select our layer and look at its
attributes you'll be able to see that
it's using this shell service in this
case and it's picking up the util and
general tags so with that information
we're able to figure out what allocation
I is eligible to run that job and what
host it should go to so if we go to our
job that's running and select one of the
frames that has finished or one of the
frames that's running we can view the
the log for that for that job and we'll
make this a little bigger here and so
this is just the standard out and
standard error from whatever process was
running in this case it's the v-ray log
and if we look at the succeeded one we
can search here for written image and
that's going to give us the path to the
file that was actually output we can go
over here where I already have that and
[Music]
launch our V and you know our frames are
are here so that's launching and running
a simple job this is just a single layer
you know one command over multiple
frames I things get a lot more
complicated when you start talking about
dependencies and hooking up I want a
layer to wait until all the frames of
one job are done or you know other
connections open queue supports
dependencies at each of the different
job levels so I job layer and frame and
you can hook up as many of those
dependencies as you want so we jumped
over here to Maya now and I'll walk
through what it looks like submitting a
job with dependencies this is from our
robot dance party
animation that was produced here at next
last year and we've set it up this time
for v-ray and Maya so it's also all
ready to go and we'll launch the queue
submit plug-in like Brendan was talking
about this is shipped as a plug-in
inside Maya but you can also launch the
queue submit widget from a command line
if you want and you can configure it to
run any kind of command so will populate
this with some information this is just
basic job info so the job name all this
stuff is already in my history so I'm
just pressing down to populate it and
we'll do the lighting pass and disarm
Maya file that we have open we'll select
the render camera and give it a frame
spec so we'll just run frames 233 250
we'll set our Maya service and give it
minimum core of 4 and for this layer we
want it to run right away so we'll go
ahead and leave the dependencies to none
but we'll add another layer and we'll
say that this is our ffmpeg pass so we
want to do something like run a make
movie after all the frames are done so
that way we can combine everything
together and I have a key command to do
that over here
well copy that in and since this is just
gonna be a single command we only want
it to run once and we'll say it's just
gonna run on frame 1 and for this we'll
leave the default service and it's only
gonna consume one core and we'll set it
to be a layer dependency so that's
meaning that it's going this layer is
gonna wait until all the frames from the
lighting layer have finished and we'll
go ahead and submit get our confirmation
close that and if we jump over to couch
Opia well refresh here and wait for a
job there's our job now has come in and
if we double click it we can see that
there are two layers here now the
lighting layer is using the Maya service
ffmpeg is using the default one and the
frame range is associated with that and
you'll see all the frames for all the
layers by default you can filter out
individual layers if you want to view
just the frames from one layer but we'll
leave it like this for now and you can
see that the lighting layers are running
and the ffmpeg layer is marked as to
depend so it's gonna sit there waiting
until all of our running frames finish
up and go and that's so a couple other
things I just wanted to go over the you
saw me going up here to this views
plugin menu a lot all these separate
widgets in cue GUI are really built on a
plugin structure so it's really easy
with just a little bit of Python to go
in and add your own widgets if you want
to have a display that hooks up to more
historical data you can create that if
you want something that's tied into
shotgun you can build that out as well
and that that about covers it through
the demo we could switch over to the
back to the presentation and to give you
just an illustration of what was going
on with the dependencies here's the
dependency tags that were submitted so
this was the the lighting render with
the ffmpeg you can see that the frames
are all feeding into the layer ffmpeg
layer and that's how that dependency is
working but these kind of dependency
tags can get pretty complicated pretty
quickly and open cue is going to ensure
that no frames are run until after all
the dependencies are met
[Music]